never thought about a career never
written a note of music for money we're
experimenting mighty big sound Arthur
black opto I remember being up for 72
hours nobody asked me to be up for 72
hours
nobody was throwing anything you know it
was fine thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me there's
something very human about it because it
can only make a sound with air and it
needs to breathe
[Music]
he's a German composer and record
producer he's the head of the film music
division at DreamWorks he's composed the
music for over 150 films including Lion
King gladiator in Pirates of the
Caribbean
he's Hans Zimmer and here's my take on
his top 10 rules for success
rule number 8 is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end for some special bonus
clips also as Hans is talking if he says
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
guy from Germany who stubbornly just
wanted to play music handsomer is a
crazy genius I just wanted the nicest
people I've ever met and a great film
composer never thought about a career
never written a note of music for money
there I don't think a few words to
define Hans the way I know him
Hans is a genius somebody who's
concerned with making sure that we will
have orchestras forever and charges
support my musician friends and try to
discover new people and never growing up
a lot of the producers go oh my god no
hands can you not write the thing that
you did so that you got an author you
get an Oscar in this and that except not
I'm going to do it all differently and
everybody's scared and in the end it's a
hit and in the end everybody copies
hands as music he's this guy that I met
37 years ago this that's come up this
written some unbelievable music and
happening and incredible career I play
music that's what I do after finishing
my adventures of Dark Knight I decided
we need to go
two completely different direction
[Music]
well I think of the notes for the tube I
try to think of what's the sonic world
figure to pour this tune into and that's
what we're doing
faces can you make your accents a bit
more fear we're experimenting
mighty big sound that's what you're
supposed to do you're not supposed to
stand still you don't really want to be
observed and your greatest failures and
you have to invite failure if you want
to go an experiment and if you have to
try to do something original we have to
have a certain amount of privacy to have
the courage to fail Black Hawk Down or
any of those films we worked on nobody
asked us to Black Hawk Down I remember
being up for 72 hours nobody asked me to
be up for 72 hours I was trying to do
something extraordinary trying to tell a
story in an extraordinary way trying to
get off the a band of brothers you know
to not let anybody else down that was on
your team it's not superhuman it's human
add up the the unfortunate thing is that
you have to put the word super in front
of it when it's it's the ambition it's
it's what we should all strive for you
know that commitment to the gesture to
the love to the how we approach today
how we approach each other how we
approach humanity how we approach art
and beauty and ultimately in Martin's
case how we approach our instrument you
know there needs to be respect at the
end of the day I don't think the issue
really is about the recording medium but
it is about the players and the Pend and
the whole team and I think you're not
going to get quite the same results by
having your mate in the flat next dog or
bag on a biscuit tin even though it
might be interesting then if you get
some yeah if you if you get the best
players in the world to go and know
where to hit it you know in a drum is of
this interesting archaic
thing but you know they're like sweet
spots when you hit it just right and you
know and and I mean
these guys have been doing it forever so
so so it's really about the human beings
that go and create the sound that
ultimately will tell you if it's any
good Lion King was of course you know it
was huge especially because I didn't for
all the wrong reasons I mean I did it
for my daughter because I wanted to show
off as dad and you know I was doing all
these grown-up movies where people are
getting killed and I couldn't take her
to a premiere I wanted to do something
to take my kid to a premiere and it was
you know and it was surprisingly
emotional during that movie you know it
deals with her father's death so you
know it's got a lot more depth then then
the surface let me believe and and it
shocked me my own response you know once
once I started writing on it because I
was thinking oh you know this is going
to be easy that it you know and it
wasn't like it was hard but but the the
emotional involvement suddenly became
you know profound as opposed to hard you
know and really was blind King that got
Terry Malick interested in me for
instance there are Terry loved Lion King
and wanted me to do Thin Red Line so you
know all these things are you know
working with Ridley Scott I mean we've
done a we've done some really good
movies together and they're
stylistically so different I mean Black
Rain is so different from Thelma Louise
is so different from gladiator so
different from Hannibal is so different
from Black Hawk Down it's so different
from matchstick men
I'm sure I'm leaving some out so you're
working with people who who are like me
that you know they get a little bored
doing the same thing and you know off
they go to try to do something
completely different I mean that's you
know it's that's just a big part of it
when I started people who are counting
on Steinbeck's and cams and now and then
they got the average and the interesting
thing about our sound guys
because sound is slightly more easy to
handle in large quantities of data than
images we've always been ahead of the of
the image guys I mean of the film guys
so we've made all those mistakes was
digital and we didn't know you know the
original the old digital recording sound
bad and it wasn't just the technologies
we didn't know how to use it you know
and part of that it's just you have to
put your hours in you know I'm a real
believer in that thing you know it's
10,000 hours to get good at something is
that the big difference between because
I see you in your basement like like a
Batman with all machines and stuff it's
really precise I guess and really what
you put you know what you put and then
you go live yeah what's the difference a
little risk the risk you know and and
the risk and I have stage fright you
know and I never confronted the risk or
when I did come from I mean Belgium
you know 2000 year 2000 that was you
have no idea but it took them to get me
to do it no no no no I had a thousand I
had a thousand excuses why not to turn
it there finally I did it and it was
exquisitely horrifying that's the only
way I can fort complex yes it was very
very very complex and what was really
good was right in the beginning within
like two seconds
I played just the worst wrong note and I
could either stop and cry or I could
laugh all right and it didn't kill me
and nobody else out there
nobody was throwing anything you know it
was fine thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me
and giving me the courage and you know
and the the absurdity you know you have
to be able to laugh at yourself
and you have to learn how to laugh at
yourself the greatest compliment I think
I've ever gotten better than Oscar Beryl
and Grammy etc was towards the end of
the last
Dark Knight Rises you know working with
those percussionist that we've just
sampled these guys have played on
everything they're the other guys you
know there's and there's nothing they
haven't played so my great ambition is
always been to go and do just one thing
where they go wow I haven't done that
before I actually figured something I've
noticed I'm not gonna go into the
details but you know number one I got
the compliment of going wow we've never
done this before and it sounds really
good I was terrible at school I never
managed to go to university but I
started working for another film
composer and what happened literally on
day one I am in the room you know my job
is to make coffee but I'm in a room with
Nick rogue who I adore as a director and
Stanley Meyers who I adored as a
composer and they're talking about the
scene and there's a real-life problem
how are we going to score the scene as
opposed to what I experienced at school
which is somebody tells you some
historical incident that then got solved
so so the the most important part of the
mentorship was and not only was I in the
room with a problem that had not been
solved and I was witnessing how this
problem in front of my eyes kept off by
Stanley going home what about those
notes and Nick going that's exactly it
but just being in a room with people who
were the best at what they did and you
know in a you know in a funny way I
thought everybody should have the right
to this it's like so I try to make this
place very you know this is a big room I
mean when it's not full of dark nights
in that there's actually a lot of room
in here and I think something really
good happens if you can be you know it's
your first day you're here to make
coffee but you're in the room with
Krishna and simmer and you're seeing
them scratching ahead and somehow even
if you don't open your mouth just by
your presence you're part of the
solution
at least you get to see it this is of
cosplay Chris gets tricky really about a
father and his relationship to his son
it's only later on that I found out that
the Sun was masala thali was a daughter
i sat down and I wrote this piece really
about what it feels like to be a father
and what it feels like to have a son and
I was writing about myself
when he played me the piece of music
which became the basis for the entire
score I thought it was absolutely
perfect and captured the emotional
qualities of the film that I wanted and
it was at that point that I told them
that's actually a large-scale
science-fiction from Rome and give many
clues about that you know it's not an
action film it's not Batman I just isn't
any instance
[Music]
I think what that did for him had set
him very firmly in a direction relating
to the heart of the film I mean I
listened to it extensively while I was
finishing writing the script
and then when we were in production
asthma the organ really is a huge
complicated synthesizer if you think
about it and see how you have a pipe and
air blows through it and that makes the
sound and it makes the sound of one
pitch then if you want to shift color
you add another pipe turn you add more
pipes and so it becomes these really
very very complex harmonic structures
and there was this endless discovery
going on for both Chris and me you know
where Roger would take us through all
these different voicings and all these
different colors you can even go a
little darker actually then we should go
through this sound
there's something very human about it
because it can only make a sound with
air and it needs to breathe
[Music]
and on each note you hear the breath
[Music]
we hear the exhale you feel human
presence and every sound
and I think that was very important to
keeping the film about not just the
space that we're looking at the people
in that space
there's an intimacy because well as
massive-scale sometimes within a few
bars there's that that shift
pulling out all the stops I now know
what that expression means for for real
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because David Dumais
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I made a profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know which rule had the biggest impact
on you what did Han say that is going to
have an impact on your life or business
somehow leave it in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout out to Fred
mcCormick Fred thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
I think I think the only thing that can
save us at the end of the day as a human
race of science and the only thing that
inspires science all the time is
dreamers you know I mean what we've
gotten to the moon without Julian or
Isaac Asimov or you know I don't know
good designers so you will fool because
we still have heart art part in art I
think I'm hopeful I'm hopeful because
I'm a musician you know and I'm
realizing this there's more and more
what what happens is it's not that we
can play really well we learn how to
listen we learn how to listen to each
other so we can come from totally
different cultures we might not be able
to speak the same words as language but
when we all get together if I got a
bunch of musicians into this room right
now and we'd start playing the first
thing we would do is we would listen to
each other and then that that comes
respect and empathy and the only way the
music can get beautiful as if we listen
to each other and I think it's something
some politicians can learn a little
something from you know all politicians
should be forced to learn an instrument
and have to jam together every weekend
they'd have to get to each other and
listen to each other because you got to
shut up you can be you can't be right
it's indefensible me it's like it's not
about being right or wrong there no
right notes are no wrong notes but it's
like I throw your note what are you
going to do with it you know it's it's
it's I know you know I'm not trying to
be pretentious about it but it's the
listening part is quite good it's not
unimportant sampling isn't the reason
that concert halls are empty what our
job is is is to drive music forward to
make it to make it interesting to make
it commercial in the best possible sense
to say you know an orchestra can rock
out I mean you can go and see an
orchestral performance and little knock
your socks off I'm just interested in
and seeing how far we can push that I
mean
movies is one way sampling is another
way life performance is another way and
the way these you know it's one of the
reasons I love working with drunky Excel
because you know I mean he does these
shows in front of 250,000 people and you
know they go they go nuts and it's just
one man and his synthesizers you know
he's just written as first symphony
which was performed in Amsterdam so you
know yes with a full orchestra so these
the these these ideas are not mutually
exclusive your tools are tools all music
relies on technology our violin is just
you know a bit of good carpentry and
some dead cats I mean it it does involve
a certain amount of technology to get
you there at the end of the day it's the
ingenuity of the play honestly ingenuity
of the composer that are going to go and
really make something out of this thing
somebody said to me recently you know
when you don't feel the nerves you have
to go and do something else
I feel the nerves trust me
[Music]
[Music]